[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
quick
[Music]
so
[Music]
thrilling stories memorable characters
and vibrant gameplay are in store
as you lead the commanding officers to
victory
[Music]
play the first two advance wars
campaigns and advance wars oneplus 2
reboot camp marching onto nintendo
switch this holiday
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
here's a new game from the head of a
certain company
did you miss me hey what do you mean who
am i
it's a me why are you
and it's a finally ready a brand new
game from
my company check it out you get to
control me
time to do this
look at me go whack rats
check out these chunks they came back
and
they have wonderful new talents
throw that stick thing not the bad
use the spinning what you might call it
nailed it same micro game
different abilities
i almost forgot some big news two people
can play together
at the same time so be nice
or else
not nice all right you yes you
the one watching this better get ready
for some micro game
mayhem
the warioware get it together game
launches exclusively on the nintendo
switch system september 10th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
get ready for the next battle
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
wins
uh
as a high school student living in tokyo
your life is
fairly normal
but that reality is upended after you
get pulled
into a different dimension
another tokyo exists a post-apocalyptic
world
where angels and demons reside
suddenly you fuse with a mysterious
figure
gaining the power to fight demons what
lies ahead in this alternate realm
the world is now transformed into a
sprawling
demon-infested wasteland though friendly
demons
do exist here many are hostile
and will attempt to destroy you harness
your newfound powers to fight demons
using a command-based system
finding their weak point is key by
targeting it
the number of consecutive actions you
can perform in a combo will increase
though demons are formidable opponents
you may be able to recruit them via
negotiations
which begin when you open a conversation
with them
[Music]
if a negotiation is successful a demon
will become a powerful ally
in some cases by rejecting a demon's
request
they may feel motivated and join you as
an ally
demons that do join will fight alongside
you and grow stronger
by fusing demon allies another demon
can be created
[Music]
the newly fused demon's innate abilities
will vary
granting you a powerful ally customized
to your needs
and play style
challenge the many demons roaming this
post-apocalyptic world
by harnessing the power of your own
what destiny will you choose
shin megami tensei 5 will launch
exclusively on nintendo switch november
12th
pre-orders for the physical version
begin june 21st
ready for another round of mario party
mayhem of course you
are it's a superstar collection of mario
party boards and mini games
live it up on five classic boards from
the nintendo 64 era
including peach's birthday cake and
space land
each board is packed with zany events
guaranteed to keep you on your toes
and when we say zany we mean it
jump connect blocks
and give facelifts in hilarious
over-the-top mini-games
all of which support button controls
with 100 mini-games from the mario party
series catalog
you'll have a blast in this all-star fun
fest
here's a little party favor all game
modes work with online play
even if you're partying solo you can
randomly match with other partygoers
worldwide
playing a board game online with friends
save your progress mid-game
grab a snack then resume the festivities
stickers are also available to
communicate with others
it's time to partay in mario party
superstars
launching on the nintendo switch system
october 29th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Applause]
um testing testing mic jack one
two this is a test of the school's rock
system
[Music]
three games in the deadly dankan rampa
series are coming to nintendo switch
the self-proclaimed school headmaster
has trapped you and other high school
students in a game
of literal life and death unfortunately
the only way out of the school and this
lethal game
is to betray the other students and so
it begins a body has been discovered
when a student meets their demise a
class trial will take place to reveal
the culprit you're the culprit aren't
you
johnny i have no idea they probably
moved the body there
use the evidence you've gathered to
refute contradictions and find the
guilty party
sneak attack
you okay
plus the board game from dunkin rompa v3
killing harmony
has been expanded into a standalone game
duncan rampa s ultimate summer camp an
all-star cast of characters from the
dunkin rumpa series will come together
to battle at a tropical resort
who's the strongest of them all in this
ultimate beach brawl
the four-game collection duncan rampa
decadence launches as a physical
exclusive on nintendo switch later this
year
all four games will also be individually
available on nintendo eshop
you